autorisation du gouvernement français
pour la création d'une société commune
de télécommunications un mariage entre
la compagnie générale d'électricité cge
et l'américain péter échec de la mission
du ministre des affaires étrangères
britanniques en afrique du sud les
autorités du cap pour opposer une fin de
non recevoir aux demandes européennes 14
heures d'intervention chirurgicale pour
réparer le pilote automobile jacques
laffite victime d'un accident au grand
prix de grande-bretagne de formule 1 il
y a deux semaines nous sommes le
mercredi 30 juillet 1986 cela fait 4 195
jours de détention pour marcel carton et
marcel fontaine 434 jours de détention
pour jean paul kauffmann et michel
seurat 144 jours de détention pour aurel
cornéa et jean louis normandin d'antenne
2 et 84 jours de détention pour camille
sonntag les sept otages français du
liban n'ont toujours pas été libérés
bonsoir à la veille des vacances l'
usine renault billancourt s'est
brutalement réveillé ce matin à l'appel
de la cgt et avec le soutien du parti
communiste les comités d'établissement
l' usine renault devaient examiner les
licenciements prévus par la direction
licenciement auquel s'opposent les
militants cgt le rassemblement de ce
matin a connu quelques instants de
violence reportage jean marc dubois et
philipp etter
les manifestants cgt contre des crs les
jets de pierres contre des grenades
lacrymogènes
pendant plus d'un quart d'heure ce matin
ils se sont affrontés devant la sous
préfecture des hauts-de-seine à boulogne
billancourt d'ailleurs assez brefs mais
violents à l'origine de ces incidents
une manifestation organisée par la cgt
ce matin devant les usines renault avec
la présence de plusieurs élus
communistes
le mot d'ordre non aux licenciements de
853 ouvriers du groupe
parmi les licences et 26 ouvriers dits
protégés délégués du personnel délégués
syndicaux symboliquement enchaînés ils
tiennent à la main leur convocation pour
le 30 juillet donc ce matin au comité
d'établissement qui doit leur signifier
les raisons de leur licenciement
or pour eux pas question d'y aller seul
alors c'est en cortège qu'ils se sont
rendus devant le lieu où devait se tenir
le comité d'établissement une
mobilisation importante pour un mois de
juillet tu plusieurs milliers de
manifestants pour la cgt un succès qui
l'encouragent à continuer
nous entendons bien à faire remettre en
cause ses décisions de licenciement et
nous emploierons tous les moyens y
compris pendant les vacances car pour
nous il n'y aura pas de grève
comme il n'y a pas de preuve pour les
mauvais coups il n'y aura pas de frais
pour la cgt les travailleurs pour mettre
en cause les décisions de la direction
du gouvernement
mais dans deux jours ce sont justement
les vacances les vraies celles d'août
renault va tourner au ralenti alors à ce
moment là la mobilisation risque elle
aussi de tourner au ralenti
la compagnie générale d'électricité la
cge et le groupe américain international
telephone and telegraph it et et ont
reçu la bénédiction du gouvernement
français le ministre de l'industrie à la
main de l'un s'est contenté d'indiquer
que l'état actionnaire de la cge ne
s'opposait pas à cet accord industriel
cela pourrait avoir des conséquences sur
une éventuelle privatisation de la
société cg commentaires dave mettait le
feu vert d'un amas de l'ain à l'accord
entre la cge et le géant américain des
télécommunications uit et et ressemble
plutôt à un nom feu rouge
même si l'accord a pu être contestée au
sein du gouvernement sans doute
aurait-il était difficile d'opposer un
refus à l'indépendance d'une entreprise
sur le point d'être cédées au privé on
entérine donc un accord signé par un pdg
sortant georges pébereau remplacé la
semaine dernière par pierre sua plus
apte selon le gouvernement a préparé la
dénationalisation l'accord dont hérite
le nouveau pdg et donne naissance au
deuxième groupe mondial de
télécommunications derrière l'autre
géant américain att
il prévoit la création d'un pôle
européen de télécommunications
représentant 10 milliards de dollars de
chiffre d'affaires annuel et un effectif
de 150 mille personnes il était
détiendrait 37% du capital
les soixante trois autres % reviennent à
une holding européenne comprenant une
participation belge et espagnole mais
sous le contrôle majoritaire de la cge
l'accord entre officiellement en vigueur
demain
mais la nouvelle société ne verra le
jour qu'à la fin de l'année
la privatisation de la cge pourrait en
être retardé bien qu'aucune date n'ait
encore été fixée
et le ministre alain madelin a annoncé
également ce matin en conseil des
ministres une baisse d'environ 11
milliards de francs des aides de l'état
aux entreprises concrétisant ainsi sa
volonté désengager l'état de la vie
économique à ce même conseil le premier
ministre a de nouveau été autorisée à
recourir à l'article 49 3 pour faire
adopter le projet de loi sur
l'audiovisuel
à partir de vendredi vendredi prochain
1er août les tarifs postaux vont
augmenter de 3,7 pour cent en moyenne
mais le tarif de la lettre la lettre
simple de moins de 20 grammes restera
inchangé à 2 francs dans l'opération
ville morte à marmande dans le
département du lot-et-garonne organisé
par les commerçants et les producteurs
exploitants et l'école la principale
production de la région normande et la
fraise la mévente de la fraise est à
l'origine du mouvement de protestation
d'aujourd'hui c'est peut-être aussi
l'une des conséquences de la catastrophe
de tchernobyl
explications avec le reportage à
marmande de bruno le dreff et frédérick
basile ville morte pendant deux heures
cet après-midi les récoltants de fraises
du lot-et-garonne ont bloqué la
circulation dans ma langue en solidarité
la plupart des commerçants avaient fermé
boutique cette année en france comme à
l'étranger les fraises se sont mal
vendus
résultat deux mille agriculteurs du
département se trouve à l'heure des
bilans
face à une situation difficile nous
allons faire du gouvernement pour le
département
merci
et 15 milliard pour la pollution
situation très difficile parce que leurs
frais de thé le menteur de recul
intégrant et beaucoup de producteurs
actuellement on en saura premier
sinon c'est du ciel et de l'est que la
menace est d'abord arrivée tchernobyl a
frappé et pourtant ici pas un becquerel
entropa l'ombre d'un nuage nucléaire
la récolte s'est effectuée dans de
parfaites conditions mais les allemands
gros importateurs n'ont rien voulu
savoir méfiants ils ont verrouillé leurs
frontières espagnols et italiens ont
envahi le marché français - protéger
résultat les cours se sont effondrés
les rentrées d'argent attendu se
transforme temps déficit c'est la
faillite
la fraise est en effet un produit à gros
rapports ses deux hectares de fraises
représentent à eux seuls 60% du chiffre
d'affaires d'une exploitation de 37
hectares en polyculture une difficultés
d'un secteur et c'est l'exploitation
tout entière qui est menacée
jusqu'à l'année dernière c'est la fraise
qui nous permettait d'investir dans
d'autres productions exemple sur le maïs
on avait investi un séchage est au poche
s'ils ont un prêt vient d'être offert
aux exploitants qui déjà prépare la
prochaine récolte
mais les fraisiculteurs estime c'est
efforts insuffisants et réclame une aide
de 350 par pied il ajoute que
l'agriculture est la première activité
du département et que la fraise et le
cordon ombilical qui maintient cette
agriculture envie manifestation ce soir
au pays basque à sarah l'appellent les
comités de soutien aux réfugiés basques
espagnols afe luis artola à menzah à
expulser de france lundi est emprisonné
depuis à madrid
cette manifestation est aussi une
réaction l'opération de police menée
hier soir près de bayonne contre des
réfugiés espagnols
plusieurs associations réunis dans la
commission de sauvegarde du droit
d'asile ont dénoncé les trois dernières
expulsions de basque espagnol vers
madrid
il joue fall président la ligue des
droits de l'homme interrogé par sophie
davant s'inquiète de pratiques non
conformes l'étape droit du sort réservé
en espagne aux expulsés estime que ce
n'est pas le bon combat contre le
terrorisme
je suis indigné parce que je considère
que
le gouvernement a fraudé à la loi sur
l'extradition
si le gouvernement espagnol a des
dossiers contre ses basques qu ils les
transmettent régulièrement au
gouvernement français que celui ci ouvre
une procédure régulière d'extradition
avec la garantie des droits de la
défense
mais ce qui est inadmissible c'est que
la police française remettent
directement à la police espagnole
les individus en question dont les
expulse comme dans un pays démocratique
c'est vrai dans un pays démocratique
mais qui a mal fait l'épuration de sa
police où de nombreux anciens partisans
du frontis brest en place ce qui n'est
dénié par personne et on sait que les
méthodes de la police espagnole ne sont
pas toujours très douce de plus en plus
le gouvernement actuel tend à donner à
la police ce qui est du domaine de la
justice
et ça c'est très grave pour la liberté
de l'ensemble des citoyens
le ministre de l'intérieur avait dit
qu'il fallait terroriser les terroristes
je crains qu'il n'aboutisse au résultat
inverse
les basques vont se trouver maintenant
comme beaucoup d'immigrés dans notre
pays dans un état d'insécurité tels
qu'ils vont devenir un danger pour la
sécurité défense ont des bacs
effondrement humiliation la presse
britannique est très sévère pour la
mission de third geoffrey au le ministre
des affaires étrangères britanniques en
afrique du sud
le gouvernement sud africain n'a en
effet pas accepter les demandes des pays
européens pour des ouvertures vers la
démocratie en afrique du sud dix mille
personnes environ ont été arrêtés ou
détenus sans inculpation depuis
l'instauration de l'état d'urgence il ya
cette semaine un grand quotidien sud
africain a publié pour la première fois
aujourd'hui une liste de trois mille
quatre cents personnes emprisonnées ou
disparus mais le ministre anglais
restent opposés malgré l'échec de sa
mission à des sanctions punitives
londres commentaire de notre
correspondant alain cances get lost
allez au diable telle est la formule par
laquelle un journal pourtant
conservateur a résumé la réponse donnée
par les sud africains le patron de la
diplomatie britannique
les autres quotidiens londoniens eux
parlent plus simplement de débâcle et
d'humiliation
complet de la mission de jeff liao en
afrique du sud est un coût extrêmement
sévère programme thatcher jusqu'au bout
elle avait espéré que les sud africains
seraient au moins un geste même petit
même symbolique pour les dairas
justifier son refus de toute sanction
économique
non seulement cela n'a pas été le cas
mais les sud-africains ont utilisé avec
sogefia au un ton aux limites du manque
de courtoisie le président pauthe a lu a
très clairement répondu mêlez vous de
vos affaires
cette attitude volontairement
provocatrice des sud africains
mais madame thatcher en situation très
difficile d'autant que premièrement le
congrès américain est lui bien prêt de
voter des sanctions
que cela plaise ou non aux présidents et
gagnent
deuxièmement les pays européens au nom
desquels parle est aussi sauf jefferies
à eau ne peuvent pas ne pas réagir
devant l'attitude sudaf et kate
troisièmement dans trois jours
commencent à londres un mini sommet du
commonwealth qui va exiger des sanctions
faute de quoi c'est le commonwealth qui
est menacée d'éclatement
quatrièmement la commission des affaires
étrangères de la chambre des communes
pourtant à majorité conservatrice a elle
aussi demandé des sanctions
il est évidente madame thatcher est
toujours proposée vise 100 chaque année
4 lapidation
et cela pour plusieurs raisons d'une
part elles les jugent inefficace et
d'autre part elle redoute leurs
conséquences certains aspects de
l'économie britannique avec un risque
accru de chômage mais cette fois elle
devra faire un geste est un ges au
sérieux ou alors prendre le risque d'un
conflit majeur avec l'autre man ouest
avec ses alliés européens et avec
certains membres de son parti
je viens d'apprendre que le principal
mouvement d'opposition à l'apartheid
sud-africain lines et le congrès
national africain a eu aujourd'hui en
zambie à lusaka un premier contact
officiel avec un représentant du
gouvernement des états unis au chili le
gouvernement du général pinochet a pris
connaissance d'une déclaration très
ferme de l'église chilienne pour la
première fois l'église accusent l'armée
de pinochet
elle affirme détenir une cassette vidéo
prouvant que les militaires ont
volontairement brûlés vifs
il y à un mois un manifestant chilien
commentaires de jean marc qui dose comme
un vulgaire pneus pendant une
manifestation il a été arrosé d'essence
et brûlés vifs avec sa compagne sur
l'autre film dit monseigneur thomass
gonzalez évêque de puntarenas on voit
clairement que ceux qui ont fait cela
l'ont fait volontairement
décidément rodrigo leur race est alors
bien encombrant pour le régime du
général pinochet
moins d'un mois après ses funérailles en
présence de l'ambassadeur américain à
santiago
voilà donc que des témoignages précis
s'oppose au démenti de l'armée
rodrigo étudiants chiliens résidant à
washington aurait bien été brûlé vif par
une patrouille de l'armée pendant une
manifestation anti gouvernementale début
juillet santiago la preuve non pas les
accusations répétées de ces manifestants
mais une cassette vidéo entre les mains
de l'église
kas est tellement accablante que pour la
première fois la très prudente église
chilienne sort de sa réserve et accuse
les soldats
vingt-cinq militaires avaient été
interrogées par la justice chilienne sur
un gros coup de coude de washington 24
avait été relâché le juge civil s'était
déclaré incompétent en matière militaire
et l'archevêque de santiago avaient
protesté sans être entendus désormais la
sphère horace devient embarrassante même
l'imperturbable général pinochet ne peut
ignorer à la fois le témoignage de
l'église les remontrances des états unis
et l'irritation croissante d'une partie
de son propre état major à l'aéroport de
genève 7 kilos et demi d'héroïne pure
ont été saisis dans le double fond des
valises d'un français qui arrivait de
new delhi cette prise est estimée à 1,5
million de francs est la plus importante
réalisée au cours des trois dernières
années en suisse toutes informations sur
le trafic de drogue préoccupe également
les autorités polonaises vous avez le
constater dans le nouveau volet de l'anc
est menée par gérard in et gilbert usant
en pologne
les jeunes dans ce pays subissent aussi
les ravages causés par la drogue gilbert
gérard in et gibert usant ont visité
officiellement un centre de réadaptation
à 80 km de varsovie un lieu pas tout à
fait comme les autres
le monarque une communauté symbole de la
lutte contre le mal qui ronge à son tour
la pologne la drogue
l'homme qui reçoit ces jeunes drogués
les patterns et les soutiens c'est lui
marijke que tu inscris un psychologue de
45 ans transformé en croisé de la lutte
anti drogue
on discute beaucoup dans cette
communauté
c'est peut-être ça l'esprit de
solidarité ici une quarantaine
d'héroïnomanes venus volontairement
tente de sortir la tête de l'eau et
d'échapper au même destin que ces
enfants perdus
j'ai 33 ans je me drogue depuis dix ans
j'ai pris toutes sortes et de drogue
je ne supportais plus ma famille une
philosophie que je ne venais déjà
échangé 18 ans je me drogue depuis deux
ans j'avais surtout des problèmes
idéologiques manque de perspectives je
ne voulais pas entrer dans le système
le problème en pologne c'est qu'il n'y a
pas eu d htap pas de marijuana pas de
lsd
les jeunes ont commencé directement avec
une drogue dure
ici on appelle ça la compote c'est une
belle saloperie
c'est plus fort que l'héroïne grosse
échéance la compote dont la fabrique à
partir du pavot ici sur ces images
prises clandestinement des jeunes
achètent des tiges de pavot une scène
devenue habituelle en pologne
la loi limite bien sûr la culture du
pavot et rend obligatoire la vente à
l'état mais faute de contrôles
suffisants
elle est restée inefficace
officiellement 300 mille personnes des
jeunes pour la plupart s'injecte ce
sirop brun c'est à la portée de tous
une dose coûte moins cher qu'une
bouteille de vodka l'interdiction totale
de la culture du pavot coûterait 16
millions de dollars à l'industrie
pharmaceutique polonaise on ferme donc
les yeux restent alors des centres comme
celui ci avec au bout une réinsertion
sans illusion
mais cela reste à ce je suis ici depuis
dix mois
la vie que je mène est normal et grise
où trônent seuls qui m'attend à
l'extérieur quand je sortirai dans un an
dans la situation actuelle je ne pense
pas que les gens acceptent de
m'accueillir
et pourtant aujourd'hui en pologne
la drogue n'est plus un tabou on en
parle dans les lycées et les groupes
rock officielle dénonce publiquement
usage de stupéfiants reste que la
défense polonaise est devenu le 2e fléau
du pays
après l'alcoolisme à la cité du vatican
le pape jean paul ii a reçu le père
lawrence genco le prêtre américain
récemment libéré par ses ravisseurs de
la jia discret amicaux du liban après
plusieurs mois de détention
le père jégo a remis au pape un message
ou ses ravisseurs
le facteur religieux est très important
dans cette affaire
je rappelle qu'il y a le rapport
américain toujours détenue en otage au
liban en politique française la loi sur
la presse sera promulguée sans les trois
dispositions annulées par le conseil
constitutionnel premier ministre a
décidé d'attendre la session
parlementaire d'automne pour proposer
une autre lourd et puis un sondage un
sondage bva up paris match à paraître
demain
jacques chirac et françois mitterrand à
gauche sont les meilleurs candidats en
cas d'élection présidentielle jacques
chirac à droite de vence raymond barre
27 % contre 23 % dans le département des
alpes-maritimes ça va mieux mais les
pompiers restent en état d'alerté
permanent patrice que les libéraux c'est
pour antenne 2 sont retournés sur les
lieux du désastre causé par les
incendies ils ont cherché à savoir si le
débroussaillement suffirait à empêcher
les feux quelles seraient leurs coûts
ça coûte environ 70 à 90 me dufranc
l'hectare et puis surtout si tout était
effectivement mis en place pour prévenir
ces incendies disparus les oliviers
lier les orangers même chose pour le
mimosa les 950 ha de la communauté sur
mer rayer de la carte un désastre évalué
à 14 millions de francs à l incendie
s'est propagé à une vitesse fulgurante
c'est la broussaille qui a communiqué le
feu à la forêt après c'était trop tard
débroussailler un mot qui revient dans
toutes les bouches ici comme l'exigent
la loi les propriétaires ont
l'obligation de nettoyer leurs terrains
restent au maire la difficulté de la
faire appliquer je n'ai jamais vraiment
de refus catégorique
seulement ça traîne il attendre
longtemps de vous répondre ça fait qu'à
ce moment là
la saison est trop avancé et ils ne
peuvent plus de broussailles et communes
vaudrait des propriétaires difficile à
joindre
il habite paris drones ou new york des
millions de francs qui ne valent plus un
sou une exploitation horticole et ce
qu'il reste des serres carte sèche 700
mille francs
des roses poussé là il y a quelques
jours pourtant son propriétaire avait
débroussaillé mais tout le monde n'a pas
les moyens il y en a qu ils évitent ce
sont bientôt 50 plus cher le
débroussaillage cas lors de nos terrains
plus loin notre exploitation horticole
et le même résultat une vie de travail
ruiné 1 ha ravagés par le feu
son propriétaire remet en cause le
débroussaillage qu'il avait pourtant
fait des broussailles et ça compte bien
sûr bien c'est indispensable c'est mais
dans les conditions de jeudi dernier
avec le vent la sécheresse c'était
insuffisant je pense avec le feu qui a
eu jeudi que ce vrai été entretenues ou
broussailleux c'est une maison de levain
avec les flammes à aller dessus ça
pourrait être propre comme broussailleux
ça brûle des propriétaires qui
s'occupent de leur terrain c'est bien
mais c'est aussi la forêt dont il
faudrait s'occuper
c'était en premier qui brûle
il n'y a plus de population de personnes
qui vivent de la forêt comme autrefois
particulièrement dans nos forêts
méditerranéennes qui rapportent très peu
d'argent et sont donc délaissé pour
éviter le désastre il faudrait trouver
les moyens financiers d'entretenir des
milliers d'hectares à eze c'est déjà
trop tard
vingt ans c'est le temps qu'il faudra
attendre avant que la forêt renaisse de
ses cendres
une semaine après l'enlèvement d'une
secrétaire de direction de la banque
porn ça paris le preneur d'otages
mystérieux s'est de nouveau manifestée
il tente de négocier une rançon en
faisant parvenir des cassettes
c'est un véritable jeu de pistes
auxquelles sont soumis les policiers par
le ravisseur
explications avec dominique tierces dans
le quartier de la place des fêtes à
paris martine pietri semblait mener une
vie paisible
un deux pièces au 17e étage de cet
immeuble un poste de secrétaire de
direction à la banque devance des
horaires réguliers mais les enquêteurs
quelques jours après sa disparition
découvraient qu'elles sortaient souvent
le soir ils pensaient même que martin
pietri avait pu rencontrer son ravisseur
dans le restaurant qu'elle fréquentait
régulièrement ce soir le témoignage de
la restauratrice de la couscous ridant
xviiie arrondissement apporte quelques
éclaircissements sur la personnalité de
martin pietri toute laiterie est une de
mes amies et revenait souvent le soir me
tenir compagnie et me donner un coup de
main lorsque j'avais du travail
et si vous pensez que c'est ici qu'il
aurait pu rencontrer son avis heures
mais jamais aucune rencontre récession
mais mes clients j'ai beaucoup de jeunes
femmes seules qui viennent dîner parce
qu'elles sont absolument trop piles et
j'ai toujours veillé à ce que personne
ne nuise quelqu'un qui est en train de
dîner tranquillement lui est arrivé de
me dire que ma vie rencontré quelqu'un
qu'elle était sortie avec quelqu'un mais
ça ne durait jamais très longtemps parce
que justement elle cherchait vraiment
quelqu'un de sérieux pour faire sa vie
et de cette personne qu'elle aurait pu
connaître je n'ai pas eu connaissance
si elle connaissait son ravisseur elle
avait dû le rencontrer il a vu peut-être
profiter que d'être d'une certaine
crédibilité il ya quand même un côté
naïf ou martin pietri ce côté romantique
qui était vraiment profondément ancrée
en elle
sept jours après la tentative de hold up
à la bande vente c'est l'enlèvement de
montrer de martine pietri les enquêteurs
son père play une nouvelle cassette est
parvenue à la police les exigences du
ravisseur sont toujours aussi confuse
une voix de femme figure sur les
enregistrements
mais rien ne prouve pour l'instant que
ce soit celle de martine pietri on a
retrouvé l'épave du titanic et quelques
centaines de kilomètres au large des
côtes de terre neuve mais c'était pas ne
sera pas renfloués cependant des
milliers de clichés photographiques ont
été pris en voici quelques uns parmi les
tous premiers montré il ya quelques
heures seulement à new york
commentaire dans celle triais à partir
de l'atlantis le bateau de l'expédition
une descente aux abîmes de 4000 mètres
dans les eaux glacées de l'atlantique
nord pour la 11e et dernière fois le
petit sous-marin alvin va tenter
d'arracher quelques secrets de plus à
l'épave du titanic des secrets enlisé
dans la vase des grands fonds depuis 74
ans il faudra des années pour étudier
les dizaines de milliers d'imagés les
bandes vidéo enregistrée par jason
junior le petit robot curieux du
professeur robert ballard mais déjà sous
la gang de rouille accumulés et malgré
les destructions
on a pu entrevoir ici un lustre de
cristal presque un tag là un cuir
instigué par les courants ailleurs de la
porcelaine et des carafes vestiges d'une
traversée insouciante images furtives du
temps qui s'est figé brusquement dans la
nuit du 12 au 13 avril 1912
il n'a pas été possible de localiser la
déchirure de plus de 100 mètres de long
provoqué par l'iceberg
la coque peu à peu c'est est trop
enfoncé dans la vase
jason junior avait plus musarder lors de
ses premières explorations dans le mess
des officiers dans la salle des
transmissions dans la cabine du
commandant sur le pont promenade mais il
n'a pas été possible de pénétrer dans la
poupe
l'arrière du bateau dans les ouvertures
sont trop petites et puis une image pas
encore diffusé à peine entrevue par un
hublot un crâne seul raulic des 1500 13
passagers et membres d'équipage disparus
cette nuit là jacques laffite est très
fatigué on serait à moi le pilote de
l'équipe ligier gitane a été opéré hier
à la polyclinique de la porte de choisy
à paris par le professeur letournel il y
avait beaucoup à faire pour réparer les
conséquences de l'accident de la fit au
grand prix de grande-bretagne bon
courage jacques laffite et voici
notamment l'avis du professeur letournel
recueillis par marc maisonneuve 13
juillet 1986 silverstone le grand prix
d'angleterre premier virage après le
départ jacques laffite et entraîné dans
la glissière par johan sonne un rail de
sécurité sans protection la coque de la
voiture se referme autour du pilote
français hospitalisé en angleterre il
est ensuite rapatrié en france
c'est le professeur letournel qui l'a
opéré une opération longue mais avec des
pauses en fait chaque intervention dans
les polytraumatisés et réalisé comme un
acte a peur
entre chaque intervention les chansons
changer des instruments nouveaux sont
employés pour la suivant et de malades
est préparé et en particulier celle
qu'avait des plâtres qu'il a fallu
enlever ensuite faire la toilette des
jambes avant de se lancer dans le
traitement des fractures des membres
inférieurs et puis il arrive aussi que
l'on puisse prendre un petit repos car
on peut pas travailler 14 heures soient
un petit peu ce rôle surtout en france
vous avez l'expérience d'autres pilotes
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faudra
recourir à tout a été fait pour qu'il
puisse courir ça toujours été ma ligne
de conduite qui m'a valu quelques fois
des critiques mais quand les pilotes de
formule 1 viennent à moi c'est parce
qu'ils ont tous et toutes les uns et les
autres ils ont touché envie de revanche
je fais tout ce que je peux pour ce qui
fut 68 ce soir jacques laffite va bien
dans quinze jours il pourra s'asseoir et
dans trois mois il pourra marcher
bientôt au volant d'une formule 1 c'est
possible d'autant que la fit l'envisager
avant même l'opération est pour demain
sur l'hippodrome d'enghien dans le prix
de lézignan voici les pronostics de
pierre de bresse
pour le quarté petit saphir l'as all in
us de bordes le 16 orix le 15 au greffe
le dise petrus jauge mai de 17 orient de
faucouzy de cette pelouse galles 13
promines sainte le 2 et pour la météo le
plaisir de retrouver brigitte sy moneta
et demain ce sera un temps de chien mais
ne vous méprenez pas je parle de la
constellation du chien dont on attirait
le mot canicule alors en fait le temps
tiens c'est du beau temps sec
malheureusement pour la moitié sud notre
anticyclone est toujours situé sur la
france mais sur la photo satellite il ya
trois éléments aussi à prendre en
considération
d'abord une perturbation qui effleura le
pays par le nord ouest
quelques entrées maritimes sur le sud
ouest et puis ces nuages qui vont
remonter sur le sud ils viennent
d'espagne
résultat sur la carte de demain une
matinée nuageuse sur les côtes de la
manche et sur le sud ouest mais cela
s'éclaircira l'après midi partout
ailleurs du vrai beau temps et en fin
d'après midi des orages sur les pyrénées
le massif central et les alpes du nord
un peu comme aujourd'hui les
températures elles restent élevés de 20
à 29 degrés sur la moitié nord de 27 à
34 degrés sur la moitié ses 34 degrés à
montélimar demain jeudi 31 juillet trois
minutes de soleil en moi il se lèvera
6h24 se couchera 21h30 et ce sera là
saint-ignace-de-loyola le patron des
jésuites le bien des zones 1 de la
rédaction d'antenne 2 où sera présenté à
23h15 par le petit saphir paul le faire
à demain 20h bonsoir merci